Well,
the man who was allegedly attacked
by the New Orleans Saints player,
someone with a camera inside a
producer, was not discharged from the
hospital. Hello, how are you, Andrés
González, with his
cousin?  out win said he
was leaving the tryst nightclub
inside the bramwell hotel and casino on
saturday around 6:30
in the morning and while trying to
get on the elevator cameraman allegedly
put his hand on the victim's chest
rendered that he tried to get out  the hand and it
was there where several people
attacked him the metropolitan police said
that the video recordings support the
argument of green
camera  March 8
Concerns continue at the
Clark County School District after
a series of violent events
lo  The teachers say that this problem
is getting worse and it is also spreading on
social networks. The yes teacher says
that fights within schools
are nothing new. Two were recently
reported, one at Legacy and the other
at Las Vegas' High.  school both
students involved now face
criminal charges
and to maintain a healthy little heart
doctors recommend a
healthy diet which means
low sodium consumption and avoid
fatty foods control food try to
follow a diet to balance your
blood pressure or if you suffer from diabetes  it is
important that they recognize the symptoms
of a possible heart attack such as
severe chest pain sweating and dizziness
many doctors see an increase in
patients with high blood pressure more than anything
due to the stress caused by the
pandemic cardiologists tell us that the young
increase the  swelling in the body
which can cause blood clotting
and now we will see the prognosis  With the
weather we will have pleasant temperatures
reaching 70 degrees today it
will feel like spring for the
rest of the week we will enjoy
these highs every day with
sunny skies and lows in the 50s
have a nice day
greet you 3  gonzález with informative envelope
of Hindus now in Spanish
[Music]